- [Narrator] We have the graph
of y is equal to h of x right over here.
They ask us does the
intermediate value theorem
apply to h over the closed interval
from negative one to four.
The closed interval from
negative one to four
right over here.
We can first remind ourselves what is
the intermediate value theorem.
Although you don't have to even know
what the theorem is actually saying,
you just have to remember that
the intermediate value theorem
only applies over closed intervals
where the function is continuous.
You just have to say, you might
be tempted to say wait, wait
this function has a point of discontinuity
but this is outside of that interval.
The interval we care
about at negative one,
this is the value of h of x
and then at four this is the value
of h of x and you can see over
that entire interval right over here,
the function is continuous.
First, I would definitely say it meets
the continuity requirement,
it's continuous
over this closed interval.
I would say yes, it does,
the intermediate value theorem does apply.
Since it does apply, I will be
able to say that by the
intermediate value theorem
because we are continuous
over this closed interval,
the function in this case, h of x
will take on every value between
h of negative one and h of four,
including those values.
H of negative one, eyeballing it,
looks like it's negative three.
H of four looks like it's zero.
We know by the intermediate value theorem
that we take on every value
between negative three and zero.
You can even see that right over here.
It actually does take on every one
of those values in this part of the curve
right over there.
Let's do another example.
Here we're asked does the
extreme value theorem apply
to g over the closed interval
from zero to five.
Once again before we even think about
what the extreme value theorem says,
we have to remember that just like
the intermediate value theorem
it only applies over closed intervals
where the function is continuous
over the entire interval.
Let's see, is our function continuous
on the closed interval from zero to five?
From zero to five.
No we clearly have a discontinuity
right over here at x is equal to three.
First of all, we would say no.
We can't say that over
this closed interval,
that we have a well defined
maximum or minimum value.
This is actually very clear over here
that you don't have well
defined maximum value,
we approach infinity over there
and then we approach
negative infinity over there.
Extreme value theorem does not apply.
If instead it had offered
us a closed interval
where we were continuous,
say they said between
negative two and zero, let's
say it's that interval.
It is a different color.
Say it's between negative two and zero.
Then the extreme value theorem would apply
where you would say
okay, over this interval,
the function has a well
defined minimum value
and a maximum value.
In this case it would actually be,
the maximum would happen
at the right bound
and the minimum value
happens at the left bound.
But for this case, the closed interval,
the one that we started with,
definitely is not continuous so we do not,
we would not say that the
extreme value theorem applies.
Let's do one more example.
Does the extreme value theorem apply
to f over the interval from
negative five to negative two?
Once again, let's just
look at the interval.
We're going from negative
five to negative two.
This is our function over that interval
from x equals negative five
to x equals negative two.
Even though there is a discontinuity
in this graph that we
see, it's sitting outside
of the interval.
We only care about what's
happening inside of the interval.
There we actually are continuous.
We're continuous over
this closed interval.
Because of that we know that
the extreme value theorem
would apply, that there is a well defined
minimum and maximum
value over the interval.
You can see that the maximum value here
happens when at f of negative two,
it's looks like it's around negative 3.5
or so, or negative 3.6.
Then the minimum value over this interval
looks like it happens
at f of negative five.
It looks like it's pretty
close to negative four
because it looks like
we're just increasing
over this entire interval.
But the important thing here
is to recognize continuity.
Continuity does not have to apply
to the entire function or
over its entire domain,
it just has to be true
over the closed interval
that we are trying to
apply these theorems to.